Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am going
to explain a Japanese Romance Drama film
called “My Tomorrow Your Yesterday.”
Spoilers ahead! Watch out and take care!
It is the 15th of February. A 20 year old boy
named Takatoshi Minamiyama from Kyoto encounters
a beautiful girl named Emi Fujuku on a train while
on his way to college. He is instantly smitten by
her and he calls it love at first sight. Takatoshi
is a visual arts undergraduate student and
political satirist. Tatakoshi is shy by nature and
initially suppresses his feelings but ultimately
decides to approach her. He deliberately misses
his stop to talk to her. After getting off at
her station, he awkwardly tells her that he has
fallen in love with her and asks for her email.
When she tells him that she doesn’t have an email,
Takatoshi thinks she is turning him down and
proceeds to leave but Emi stops him and assures
him that she really doesn’t use an email. The two
then sit on a bench and get to know each other.
Emi reveals that she is a 20 years old cosmetology
student and she recently moved to the city.
When Emi asks him why he wanted to talk to her
out of all the girls on the train, Takatoshi tells
her that he felt a sudden instinct to approach her
which he can’t explain in words. He says that
he felt like he has known her for a long time.
Takatoshi proceeds to tell her something about
the Takaragaike lake but Emi suddenly gets up
and tells him that she has to get going. Before
parting ways, Takatoshi asks Emi if they will meet
again. This for some reason makes her emotional
and she says, “Until Tomorrow” before leaving.
At school, Takatoshi tells his best friend
Shoichi Ueyama, who is good with girls,
about Emi. Ueyama finds it hard to believe that
a shy nerd like Takatoshi asked a girl for his
phone number. Meanwhile, the latter is worried
if he will meet Emi again and Ueyama assures
him that Emi will come looking for him.
The next day, Takatoshi looks for Emi on
the train but doesn’t see her. Dejected, he goes
to the zoo to draw sketches for his assignment.
To his surprise, Emi approaches him at the zoo.
She compliments her drawing and comments that his
school should definitely display his drawing.
However, Tatakoshi is puzzled thinking how Emi
found him at the zoo. Emi tells him that he told
her his plans at the zoo in their last meeting
and changes the topic. Tatakoshi is puzzled as
to when he said this but he is soon cut off by
Emi. She asks him what he wanted to tell her about
the Takaragaike lake the last time and Takatoshi
tells her that it is one of his favourite places.
He takes her there and reveals that he once fell
off the pier and almost drowned in the lake when
he was saved by a woman. Emi reveals that she too
once almost died when she was five. This is a
strange coincidence that both of them share.
This time, Emi gives Takatoshi her phone number
before parting ways. After returning home,
Tatakoshi tells Ueyama that he finally got Emi’s
number and Ueyama encourages him to ask her out
on a date. Tatakoshi obligies and calls her but
doesn’t know how to ask her out. There, Ueyama
writes cards for him and helps him ask her out.
The next day, Takatoshi learns that his school has
displayed his drawing on the board. Following
the tips from his friend, Takatoshi goes to
explore his dating spot by himself so he could
be as confident as possible before meeting Emi.
Takatoshi then takes Emi to the same spot and
shows her an awesome time. He also takes her
to a movie and the date goes really well.
At the end of the date, Takatoshi musters
the courage to ask Emi to be his girlfriend.
Emi points out her flaws such as her emotions
but Takatoshi tells her that he loves everything
about her. This too makes the girl tear up.
The next day, she shows up at Takatoshi’s house
to help him move to his new apartment, where she
finally meets his best friend Ueyama. After moving
the stuff in, Ueyama leaves but Emi stays with
Takatoshi to help him organize his apartment.
She finds a mysterious box in one of the large
carton boxes and Takatoshi reveals that he met the
woman, who saved him from drowning at the lake,
at a market 5 years ago and she gave him the box.
He also reveals that she asked him to not open
the box until they meet again. After arranging
his home, Takatoshi walks Emi to the station
and on the way, he musters up some courage
and nervously asks if he can hold her hand.
She obliges and they hold each other’s hand for
the first time. Takatoshi is extremely happy as he
is holding a girl’s hand for the first time while
Emi gets emotional and begins crying again.
Emi and Takatoshi start spending more and
more time with each other. Emi cooks for
him and her cooking surprises him as her
food tastes just like his mother’s cooking.
Emi speculates that maybe his mother
adds chocolate in her food just like her.
This surprises Takatoshi as he had never told
her that his mother adds chocolate in her dishes.
Takatoshi finds it strange that Emi is
able to predict things about his life
as she had earlier predicted that his drawing
of a giraffe would be displayed at the school.
However, Emi laughs it off and asks him what
he would do if she could predict the future.
Takatoshi jokingly replies that he would
gamble all day and become filthy rich.
The two continue to spend more time together
and on the fifteenth day, the two make love
which again makes Emi emotional. It is getting
late again and Takatoshi walks Emi to the train
station. After returning home, Takatoshi finds
Emi’s journal on his table and goes through it. Lo
and behold, the diary contains future predictions
of the next 15 days. The first entry is dated
March 16 while the last entry is March 1. In an
entry from March 15, Emi has written that she
met Takatoshoi’s parents. It seems Emi has written
them as if she is racing through time backwards.
Takatoshi then receives a call from Emi and it
is revealed that she deliberately left the diary
on his table. She promises to tell him everything
and asks him to meet her tomorrow in his classroom
at 6 am. She also asks him to bring the mysterious
box with him. Just as the clock strikes 12
and before Takatoshi could get a word in, Emi
disappears from the phone booth like a ghost.
The next day, Emi meets him in the classroom and
tells him that she is from a parallel world where
time moves in the opposite direction. In other
words, what's the future for Takatoshi is the past
for Emi and vice versa. This explains how Emi knew
that Takatoshi’s picture was going to be displayed
in his school. Takatoshi is left stunned by the
revelation and doesn’t believe any of it at first,
but when Emi tells her how she knew of his
mother’s secret recipe without ever meeting her,
he starts trusting her.
Emi then opens the box that
the woman who saved Takatoshi from drowning gave
to him. Takatoshi is shocked to see a picture of
Emi with his parents and him. She explains that
the picture is from her past i.e. his future. Emi
has been watching Takatoshi from afar since he
was young and she was the adult woman who saved
him and gave him the box. It is also revealed
that Takatoshi will save her from dying when
she will be 5. Because her memories of him fade
as time goes on and her time goes backwards,
she keeps a journal to remind her of him. She
also tells him that they can only be together
for a month every five years because that’s
when Emi’s universe and Tatakoshi’s universe
synchronizes. Moreover, 20 is the only time their
age matches and the current month is the last time
where they can pursue a relationship.
Despite them fast drifting apart,
Emi tries to enjoy the moment but Takatoshi
feels conflicted about the fake nature
of his and Emi's relationship. He tells her that
he can’t continue like this, saying he doesn’t
want to enact a script from someone’s diary.
He meets his friend at the laundry shop and
without revealing any details, he tells him
that Emi and he are moving past each other.
Takatoshi compares Emi and himself to the earth
and moon that’s drifting away 4 centimetres from
each other every year. However, Ueyama makes him
realize that it gives them all the more reason
to make the best of the time they have left
together. Suddenly, Takatoshi comprehends the
reason why Emi used to get emotional all the time.
Takatoshi’s first meeting with Emi on the train
is actually Emi’s last, but Emi still acts as
if she has met Takatoshi for the first time.
Realizing this, Takatoshi becomes devastated
as Emi has been sacrificing her feelings
just to stay relevant with the timeline. He then
immediately calls her and apologizes to her. From
that day on the two spend their remaining days
together cherishing every moment together.
On March 15, Takatoshi takes Emi to his hometown.
He shows her his favourite restaurant. Emi loves
the food and stomps her foot on the ground like
a child in excitement. In a flashback scene,
Takatoshi tells Emi that he only plays
football because his dad loves to see
him playing it. He tells her that when he
grows up, he wants to be a comic artist.
Back to the present, the lovebirds go to meet
Takatoshi’s parents. They are given a cold welcome
by his father but his mother is elated to see
his girlfriend. Takatoshi’s mother makes dinner
for them and tells Emi about his childhood. When
Takatoshi’s father leaves after having dinner, his
mother tells Emi that he only acts cold in front
of others but deep down he cares a lot about his
son. The couple then takes the same family picture
from the box before leaving. On their way back,
Takatoshi breaks into tears, despairing over
the family he won’t get to start with Emi.
March 16 finally arrives. It is the last day
they would be together as equals. This is the
last day for Tatakoshi while it is the first day
for Emi. This Emi doesn’t remember how Tatakoshi
and her spent the previous 30 days together as
every midnight, a new Emi meets Tatakoshi.
They meet at Tatakoshi’s class because he has
been meaning to draw her since he first saw her.
Emi has a diary in which she has written how
she broadly spends her time with Tatakoshi
according to what the 25 year old Tatakoshi told
her so she asks a 20 year old Tatakoshi to tell
everything about their time together
in the last 30 days in as much detail
as possible. She asks him this as from
now on, she intends to use this updated
diary to relive their time together.
Takatoshi then delightfully explains
to her about the blissful days while
drawing her. This brings him to tears.
Later, Takatoshi stays with Emi till midnight.
A few moments before midnight, Emi asks him what
kind of girlfriend she was and if he was happy
with her. Tatakoshi tells her that the last 30
days with her were the best period of his life. He
also tells her that they are not drifting apart.
The edges have been tied into a ring connecting
them as one life. The clock finally strikes 12 and
Emi disappears. This makes Tatakoshi annoyed
but once he grasps reality, he calms down.
Five years pass by. Tatakoshi is now 25. He meets
a 15 year old Emi and shows her the painting
he drew of her 5 years ago. Emi notes how the
future Tatakoshi is more mature and wonderful.
A further ten years later, Takatoshi rescues
5-year-old Emi from a festival fire. The film
then cuts to a montage of the film presented from
Emi's perspective, in backwards, ending with her
and Takatoshi's introduction on February 15 on
the train, her last day she met him as equals
.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on the notification, and leave a like to
help the channel out. Thanks for watching.